[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
[Applaudissements] [
Musique]
Musique] s'il
vous plaît [
Musique]
[Applaudissements] les
peuples autochtones se battent contre
cela depuis longtemps
euh et poussent les peaux rouges et
poussent  la nfl
depuis longtemps pour changer de nom
euh et donc aujourd'hui c'est un jour de victoire pour les
indigènes
il ne s'agit pas seulement de cette mascotte raciste
ou de ce nom raciste qui nous déshumanise mais
que la déshumanisation a un
rapport direct avec les défis
et les injustices  que nous ressentons en fait
l'emprisonnement excessif des
Noirs et des indigènes, vous
savez, les taux plus élevés de diabète
et euh et comment
et les déterminants de la santé, les
taux de pauvreté et de chômage les plus bas de
la nation
sont dans les communautés noires et indigènes
et ainsi de suite euh  et donc ce sont
nos réalités auxquelles nous sommes
confrontés aujourd'hui
[Musique]
le raskin est une famille c'est tout ce que nous sommes
vous savez que
nous n'avons rien du tout contre les amérindiens et en
fait certains des
amérindiens soutiennent l'équipe  depuis que je
suis une petite fille, j'ai toujours rencontré un
fan des redskins, donc
la honte de changer le nom, c'est comme changer
tout ce que j'ai dans ma maison
et tout le reste parce que j'ai grandi à
washington dc
et c'est chez moi et c'est tout ce que je sais
ce qui s'est passé comme  autant que vous sachiez
comment ils sont devenus des Amérindiens comme
ça c'est le problème
et nous ne devrions pas juste comme les
Noirs se sont levés
j'ai l'impression que les Amérindiens ils devraient
avoir les mêmes droits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[  Musique]
[Musique]
vous